[Music]
hi there I'm Jenny I'm a sales trainer
with Google cloud and hello again for me
Heather on today's episode we'll give
you a high-level overview of App Engine
this is really critical for folks that
have a great idea for an app but don't
want to mess around with figuring out a
development platform that's right it
gives them the autonomy to focus on
writing their app and perfecting their
code make sure to stick around with us
as we run through a quick demo of the
self-paced lab that's going to allow you
to download tests and deploy an app so
Heather what would you focus on when
considering a development platform so
solid infrastructure is definitely top
of mind and this is something that is
commonly brought up when I meet with
developers totally app engines an
integral part of the Google cloud
platform it's going to provide
everything needed to build for the cloud
app engine takes care of deploying
running and scaling your app and this is
going to allow developers to spend more
of their time on building testing and
deploying apps for web mobile and even
back-end solutions all developers hope
that their apps will go big so
scalability is an important
consideration too with App Engine apps
automatically scale at a moment's notice
to handle large or small amounts of
traffic keep in mind that you only pay
for the capacity that you use that's
true a developer's data is also very
important an app engine provides a range
of choices for how data can be stored
and retrieved oh and there's language
too many developers have preferred
language so it's great that App Engine
supports a range of languages out of the
box this allows them to be more
productive immediately in a familiar
environment
so I'm pretty confident that we've now
answered the question why App Engine
yeah I think so too there are features
of course including being able to bring
any library and framework into App
Engine run multiple app versions and
micro-services split traffic between
versions access diagnostic for app
monitoring and debugging and of course
app security check out the description
below for some awesome documentation
that will get you well on your way in
your programming language of choice now
the fun part
quick labs to cater for different
languages we have provided versions for
Python Java PHP and go you can check out
the links below to start the quick labs
each of these labs will cover the
activities of downloading testing and
deploying an app and each is going to
take you about 30 minutes to complete at
this point in the lab we've cloned a
simple Python HelloWorld application and
tested it using the Google cloud
development server which is included in
the pre-installed App Engine SDK next
you're going to deploy the app to App
Engine
you will be prompted for a region you'll
be prompted to confirm the deployment
you can then view your deployed
application well there you have it we
hope you enjoyed this episode and would
love to hear more about how you use or
would use Google App Engine don't forget
to keep visiting our on-air webinar
series quick labs and our blogs all
those links are right below you can also
learn more about App Engine through our
on-demand courses on Coursera thanks for
watching happy coding and see you soon
need a way to manage your data check out
our last episode where we highlight an
Tambo Google bigquery
[Music]